les cent vingt mille documents de la
médiathèque du canal ont retrouvé leurs
lecteurs depuis le 17 juin le public est
de retour
mais pour limiter les contacts les
équipes se sont mises au drive comme de
nombreux sites l'organisation été
repensé par la trentaine de salariés
toute l'équipe est sur le pont pour
rechercher les réservations fairly près
gérer les retours via la boîte de retour
la mise en quarantaine des documents
voilà il ya toute une logistique
derrière la prise de rendez vous on a
mis en place un accueil téléphonique
avec des lignes supplémentaires pour
répondre à un maximum ou
aux questions et de demandes pour
renforcer les consignes sanitaires les
équipes mettent de côté les ouvrages
pendant trois jours selon les
recommandations du ministère
réservations sur internet est prise deux
créneaux horaires en deux jours la
médiathèque a reçu plus de 1000
commandes
on est un peu déçu que ce soit que cinq
livres par réservation ce que moi j'ai
un petit garçon qui lit très vite et on
aimerait bien pouvoir réserver un peu
plus mais bah sinon c'est quand même
mieux que rien et on vient le mercredi
et le samedi pour pouvoir avoir assez de
livres arrière contente de retrouver
toute l'équipe
voilà que pouvoir pouvoir lire aussi
pour cet été ça tombe très bien
j'utilisais beaucoup en fait toutes les
semaines je prenais je rendais surtout
avec les enfants c'était pratique et la
bombe à ça on emprunte peut-être moins
mai
en emprunts 5 médiathèque propose
actuellement un drive elles sont
complétées par le bibliobus deux autres
accepte seulement les retours avant de
proposer des services plus élargie à
partir du 7 juillet